si 2,5 milliards de doses de vaccins ont
été inoculés dans le monde à peine plus
de 1% de la population africaine est
vaccinée contre le colis de 19 en europe
et aussi la vente der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne
fanfaronne 70% de la population adulte
est vaccinée dans l'union européenne est
le constat est autre en afrique selon
les nations unies près de 80% des pays
africains n'ont pas atteint l'objectif
mondial de vacciner un dixième de leur
population ce mois ci alors que le
continent africain peine à recevoir des
vaccins l'europe et les états unis font
la course à la troisième dose et ont
même le luxe de pouvoir jeter des doses
de vaccin à foison prenez les états unis
au moins 15 millions de doses de vaccins
ont été jetés depuis le 1er mars selon
les autorités sanitaires américaines et
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée ces
doses auraient permis de vacciner les
trois quarts d'un pays comme le mali qui
compte un peu moins de 20 millions
d'habitants alors la question c'est
pourquoi ces doses sont gâchées bien
plusieurs raisons mais surtout un
surplus de commandes et des l'annnonce
de la troisième dose l'organisation
mondiale de la santé est monté au
créneau et a dénoncé l'égoïsme des pays
riches et qui s'accaparent les dos
tandis que la quasi totalité des pays
pauvres n'ont pas encore vu l'ombre
d'une les pays riches comment c'est à
dire nous avons contrôlé le virus ce
n'est plus notre problème je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il soit tiré d'affaires et je ne
suis pas sûr non plus qu'il est contrôlé
à cause du variant delta et des autres
variant qui pourrait émerger je suis
désolé de dire ça mais si la solidarité
ne fonctionne pas tout le monde sait
pourquoi c'est à cause de la cupidité
personne n'est encore tiré d'affaires
dans cette histoire et puis il est
encore plus gourmand au royaume uni par
exemple pays compte un peu plus de 66
millions d'habitants et à acheter
467 millions de doses pour cette année
selon le british medical john on
dénombre près de 219 millions de doses
de surplus cette année seulement est les
calculs ne sont vraiment pas bon
retournons en france à présent avant
l'été le ministère de la santé estimé
les pertes à 100 % seulement
mais dès le mois de mars est la ministre
déléguée à lundi ce tri agnès
pannier-runacher expliqué que moins d'un
pour cent des doses étaient perdus
soixante dix mille doses mais il reste
tout de même difficile d'avoir des
chiffres actualisés à ce sujet il en a
elles qui administre déjà une troisième
dose à sa population a proposé de
fournir un million de doses fighter sur
le point d'être périmés à l'autorité
palestinienne
une offre bien évidemment refusé constat
cuisant l'égalité des chances c'est pas
pour aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la loi du
plus fort